.
What I would like to do now in this presentation is a set of
Examples of very simple discrepancies
But its real value, I think, will take you to
Real understanding of discrepancies
So let's start with the first example
If we have x - 5 <35
Let's see if we can find all the x values ​​that are
Check this equation
This is one of the differentiated characteristics
In the equation, we have one solution, or at least
In equations that we have solved
Either in the future, you will see the equations possess more
Of one solution
But in those that we just solved, we found value
x specific
In Variants, there is a complete set of x values ​​that
Check this variance
If what we are told is: What are all x values ​​that are when
Subtract 5, the output will be less than 35?
Indeed, we can think about it
I mean 0-5
This is less than 35
-100-5
Less than 35
5-5
So clearly there are many x values ​​that will achieve this
But what we want to do is get a solution
Includes all these x values
The method of values ​​in this way is considered the same as that
We solve any equation
We want to put x statements, in this case, on
The left side
So I'll get rid of this -5, and I can do it
By adding 5 to both sides of this equation
If I can add 5 to both sides of this equation
This will not change the variance
Will not change the signal of less than
If something is less than something else, something +
5 will remain less than the other thing + 5
If we have x on the left side
These 5 and 5 are deleted
x <35 + 5, ie 40
That is the solution
In order to visualize a set all the numbers are
Represent it, let me draw a line here
Let me draw a line here
I will put it around - suppose this is 40
This is 40, 41, 42
And then we move to less than 40
39, 38
You can continue to be less than 40
Will continue indefinitely in both directions
Any x less than 40 will achieve it
It can not equal 40, because if x = 40
The 40 - 5 = 35
It is not less than 35
If x must be less than 40
To make this clear on the line of preparation, put a circle around the 40
To make it clear that we will not include the 40
But later we can parse everything under 40
If we include everything less than 40
In the solution group
If everything you shaded in yellow we will include it in
Set Solution
If 39, 39.999999 league, it is very close
Of the 40, we include it within the solution group
But the 40 did not
That's why we put that open circle around
Let us solve another example
Let me give it another color
Suppose we have x - let me write it in this
Upper-right corner -
Suppose we have x + 15> =
-60
Notice that we now have greater than or equal to
So let's solve it the same way we used to solve
That example is there
We can ask 15 from both parties
I prefer to change the code
Here you add the 5, on the same line
You can also pool or subtract
The line is so
If I ask 15 of both parties, I will ask 15 of them
Here, throw 15 from here
I have x left side
Because I clearly have 15-5
It is deleted
We get x> = -60
- 15 = -75
If something is bigger than or equal to something else, if
I took 15 of this and so, the signal was bigger than or
Equals will still exist
If the solution is x> =
Let's represent it on the line of preparation
Let me draw a line here
I will have - suppose these 75, and those
74, those -73, and those -76
and so on
I can continue to set stuff
Now, x> = -75
If x can equal -75
Thus we can complement it, because we have a larger signal
Of or equal to
They noticed that we did not make it as empty as that
But we have completed it because it can be equal
-75, or even greater
If greater than or equal to
We will highlight everything above 75 as well
If the solution set is in orange
We can clearly continue on the right. x
It can be worth a million, and can be worth a billion
It can be anything
It has to be any big number, as long as it's bigger
From or equal to 75
Let's solve more
Suppose x - 2 <= 1
Again, we will put x on
The left side
Get rid of these 2
Let us add 2 to the two extremes of this equation
+ 2
The left side becomes x
Our signal is less than or equal to
It will not change by adding or subtracting the same thing
For the two extremes
Then that 1 + 2 = 3
If x <= 3
Any x value of less than or equal to 3
Will achieve the equation
So let us help it
I will try any x value of less than or equal to 3 and
Check yourself from it's really check this out
Differentiated
I should not call it an equation
It's mixed
So let me represent the solution package
Suppose this is 0, 1, 2, 3, 4
That is -1, -2
If x must be less than or equal to 3
Can equal 3, so we will shade the point
Or less than 3
If this solution set is in pink
Anything less than or equal to 3
And check it out yourselves
If x = 3, we will get 3 - 2, which is equal to 1
This is true because it can be less than or equal to
If we put 2.999999-2, we will get 0.999999, which is
Less than 1
You can continue experimenting with any of these settings at
Set this pink solution
Let's solve more
Suppose we have x - 32 <= 0
In the same way
Let us add 32 to both sides of this equation
Add 32 to both sides of this equation
The left side becomes x, and
The right side is less than or equal to 32
Very direct
The same principle is used when representing this equation
We draw a line of numbers
If this is 32, this is 33, this is 31
I can continue to add numbers larger and less than 32
For the solution group, everything will be less than or equal to
So we can - it can equal 32, or less
So we include everything less than that
Remember, the reason we included him, ie
The reason why 32 solutions are acceptable for this
The original variance, is a signal of less than or equal to
Here, we have no less than or equal to, and for this
The 40 were not part of the solution group
.